you are looking now at live pictures
from Helsinki Finland where presidents
Trump and Putin are holding an historic
summit
welcome back to CBS this morning the two
men arrived at the finished presidential
palace a short time ago before beginning
their closed private session head of
their talks both leaders made brief
opening remarks to reporters inside the
palace the two men are meeting just
three days after the Justice Department
formally accused 12 Russian intelligence
officers of hacking Democratic Party
officials during the 2016 election
members of Congress from both parties
have condemned holding this summit right
after those indictments were announced
president Trump tells CBS News he could
have a quote very good relationship with
his Russian counterpart and wants to get
along before meeting with Vladimir Putin
President Trump sat down for an
interview with CBS Evening News anchor
Jeff Glor they spoke over the weekend at
the Trump Turnberry resort in Scotland
and Jeff is back with us in New York
Jeff quite an extraordinary interview a
lot of news made yeah just back in good
to be here bianna how much this meeting
means depends on who you talk to
president Trump mine's more of an open
conversation
those who know Vladimir Putin say he'll
want concrete steps taken Putin of
course is not new to situations like
this is the third u.s. president he's
dealt with we asked President Trump
about that President Bush said that he
saw into his soul I think he came to
regret that you said that Putin toyed
with Obama how do you ensure that things
are different in this administration
look I've met him two times two and a
half times most of you people were there
when I met him I think that I may have a
very good relationship and I think I may
have a very bad relationship with him I
have no idea I love the United States he
obviously loves Russia he's for Russia
I'm for the US we'll have to see what
comes of it but I think we have a chance
to have a very good relationship I mean
the couple of times I've met him we got
along very well there were very short
meetings but we got along very well and
if I got along with them that's a good
thing you know we're
innocent powerful country they're a very
powerful country we're a nuclear country
they're in nuclear country and getting
along is a good thing not a bad thing
the Russians who were indicted would you
ask Putin to to send them here well I
might I hadn't thought of that but I
certainly I'll be asking about it but
again this was during the Obama
administration they were doing whatever
it was during the Obama administration
and I heard that they were trying or
people were trying to hack into the RNC
to the Republican National Committee but
we had much better defenses I'd been
told that by a number of people we had
much better defenses so they couldn't
I think the DNC should be ashamed of
themselves for allowing themselves be
hacked it's the president what the goal
of this meeting was he told me tell us
after we also asked about the tone what
he'd like this to be Tony like to strike
he in this meeting he brought up
investigations again saying they hamper
relations between the US and Russia on a
continuing basis I also did ask the
president at one point who he thought
America's biggest global fall was at
this point who's your biggest competitor
the biggest foe globally right now well
I think we have a lot of foes I think
the European Union is a foe what they do
to us in trade now you wouldn't think of
the European Union but they're a foe
Russia's a foe in certain respects
China's a foe of economically certainly
they're a foe but that doesn't mean
they're bad it doesn't mean anything it
means that they're competitors they want
to do well and we want to do well and
we're starting to do well I followed up
with him it said some people might be
surprised to hear you list the EU as the
first foe before Russia China never mind
Iran others potentially and he doubled
down and he said listen they this is the
the focus right now for him and the
administration I think is so much on
this trade on redoing some of these
deals and also the NATO payments which
have been discussed so much so he stood
by that he's doubled down but then the
EU responded saying anybody that says
were a foe that's an example of fake
news
the reason it's so extraordinary is not
only as the you've been long-term allies
of the United States but Vladimir
Putin's message is that the EU is a foe
so that it occurred in part what Putin
has himself been trying to do yeah and
and it is interesting that the EU
injected itself into that debate as well
clearly a topic that is rubbing some
folks the wrong way on both sides but
one that I don't think as we've seen
clearly the president is gonna let go of
right now yeah we'll have much more of
that interview later tonight on the
evening news Jeff great to see a great
interview you can see more of Jeff's
conversation as we mentioned President
Trump on tonight's CBS Evening News then
on Wednesday the part two the president
will sit down with Jeff for a second
post summit interview in Washington some
must-see TV there yeah wait